I was on your show last week and dennis
prager was on who's a conservative radio
host who i don't agree with especially
on the social stuff and you've been a
big supporter of LGBT the gay community
and i could see you were getting into it
a little bit with him but it was it was
based in respect and honesty so this
burger off he is and i like him yeah i
don't agree with him i think out the gay
issue he's way off track but he comes
from a religious bent and he asked the
question that cause you thinking one one
thing i like i like about questions of
course it when dennis prager said if you
had two people you're the judge
someone's gonna get this child a gay
couple or a heterosexual couple and
they're equally valued who would give
the child to and i think the correct
answer you might give it to the gay
couple you might but it wouldn't depend
on that but i can see where he's coming
from where you can make a case for that
and i like great moral arguments like
that when that someone's presented to me
because it causes what we want to do is
think we want to progress we want to
think i read an article the other day
should we be mad at Woody Allen
should we not see a Woody Allen movie
because of what he did with supposedly
his young son should we not so and the
question was posed this way and I love
this supposin I showed you a great
painting and you loved it
what a painting it captured drama and
then I told you Hitler painted it was
your opinion of the painting change it
probably would why I guess that wouldn't
be in the most purest artists sense of
it but if knowing where it came from can
you separate the art from the artists
but those are great moral questions we
ask them all the time that's the kind of
thing I like that's the kind of
give-and-take where you could have a
guest i group may not want to buy the
painting but the guest could defend get
buying the painting on its value at its
core yeah right and that's those are
great arguments that you don't see
anymore so speaking of that do you see
the the game
movement as sort of the civil-rights I
do it I think of our time however I went
through a lot of things you know when
you've been in business 57 years I was
in Miami when Anita Bryant yeah started
the must be civil movement and it was an
anti-gay movement and we had a ballot to
give gays the right to open housing in
the biggest attack on that vote was the
blacks they voted 98% against it against
a bill and would have given gays
complete rights in Miami and the reason
was they said don't put us in the gay
rights category we we have a color wrong
yeah we're not gays that's completely
changed gay is a civil rights issue and
what the the people opposed to it have
to face is it's a losing war right
you're done Cody so what about the
politicians then because these people if
they want one thing it's to remain in
power right and that's the part that I
don't change I saw George Wallace yeah
go from barring the door at the
University of Alabama not letting a
student enter to his chief of staff
being black yeah I sorta I I lived in us
when I arrived in Miami to break into
broadcasting I got off the train and the
first thing I saw was a water fountain
that said color only and I drank out of
that fountain it was good water but then
I got on a bus to go over to Miami Beach
to stay with my uncle and I sat in the
back of the bus and the bus driver
pulled over and said you have to move to
the front just the back of the bus is
for Negroes and the front of buses for
whites I couldn't believe it I was from
Brooklyn so I said my father's black
duty of segregation yeah be the utter
stupidity of it but I'm in Miami a
progressive City in 1957 blacks and
whites couldn't compete against each
other on the football field they could
not now mrs. all these teams not the
entire Mississippi basketball teams
black yeah Alabama basketball team is
why
oh yeah no it's just yeah so now we've
seen that acquit we have a black
president yes we'll have a gay president
yes we'll have a female person life is
change and the politician will have to
change along with it or blues right well
you've given me a perfect segue then to
let's do a little bit of political
footballing so 2016 is coming we've
talked a little bit about it on your
show Hillary is I mean is it a foregone
conclusion as much as I don't know she
wants it she's the nominee I don't think
any I don't think Biden will run against
her I think with the promise that he'll
be Secretary of State
I think that's logical to think that it
would be a great secretary what do you
make of the idea that we'd have these
families then you know it would be the
bushes in the question she's totally
opposed against it yeah Barbara Bush
doesn't want Jeb to run yeah you know
she says I love Barbara Bush one of my
favorite people all tell me stop with
this already
stop with the bushes and the clean mop
yeah we've had enough but isn't that how
most of America feels don't you think
that we're sort of being this is just
being pushed on us again like oh now Jan
and now Hillary and then it's gonna be
Malia 2024 in Chelsea 2030 or switch
those two you know you know what
Americans like it and you know why
Americans like it because John Kennedy
said it best what Americans really want
is a kind king that is leave us alone
now if you could do that as the Adams is
or the bushes or had John Kennedy with
the Kennedys Robert would have been
president right
Ted if yet maybe child didn't have
Chappaquiddick he'd oven we'd like that
it's there's in something inside of us
likes the fact that we have this family
protector it's a god-like thing they're
our protector you know and doesn't it
seem sort of backwards though to how our
country was born because we left England
because that yeah so what do you think
that says about I think Kennedy had a
right we'd like to kind King quitters
you know the decision to make just don't
bother us NORs don't throw us in jail
for a crime we didn't commit
yeah don't prevent us from doing things
we want to do but
be nice yeah just be nice don't send up
citizens off to war where they're gonna
get killed unless he can really justify
just be nice kind king kind king